and that news breaking right now at 11  the supreme court of nevada  denying the trump campaign's request to  overturn the state's elections results  yeah brian the ruling coming down just  in fact here in the last hour  the court unanimously agreeing with a  lower court judge who said the evidence  he saw  showed no widespread voter fraud in our  state  this ends the trump campaign's attempts  in court president-elect joe biden of  course won nevada's six  electoral votes by a margin of more than  33 000 votes so let's tell you what the  nevada republican party is responding to  this they admitted that they are  disappointed with the decision  a statement reads in part full denial of  legitimate due  process and appellate rights is truly  unprecedented  shocking and extraordinary